I got a really good hand I'm gonna win
yes wow that's a challenge or decline in
law so I will I will
oh oh would play seven I want to my turn
here's gonna play this seven ahead
[ __ ] you hey welcome to last jag it's
the best a normal card but yet enix what
don't press 8 if you have a green 8 you
can press it and jump in you can click
on it oh yeah I tried to do that it
didn't work that's alright here I'll
give you another chance
dick not blue I had to draw it it's not
like I'm loser loser watch me draw those
cards ok it was happening I went from
first to last very quick drawing so many
cars garbage what do you wanna do I
can't keep it
[ __ ] Wade's gonna win no I can't
I cannot win don't worry I got this he
cannot win guys it's impossible hard
words play draw to track you can do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was only a one card up challenge no
that's not a wild then you and you play
a while and he challenges you then you
lose the challenge and you draw the
cards so you had a card I could have
played aside from the wild haha
you should oh okay the [ __ ] yeah why
does it back to me I'm not jumping
Oh [ __ ] suck ha all right well man
uno is [ __ ] Savage yeah yeah [ __ ]
Wow
that's like the first normal court I've
got to play in a while thank God no
[Music]
turns quick quick quick there's like
team up against Wade
well that's ways that's just depressing
oh wait hey balls okay blue yellow or
not the colors guys please yeah yeah
blue and yellow are cool man they seem
good to me have I ever told you the
story about Darth Plagueis the wise no
oh well it's a story the Jedi would not
tell you tell me
gee I wonder what he's gonna do oh no no
no no no after you I got a plan oh I
don't know what I did I have a serious
problem with this hand no don't jump in
I gotta draw
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate all of you a card you took it
away from me Oh when you tend to two
cards you have to click on the bottom
right before you play a wonder somebody
can make you draw more oh you [ __ ]
dick wait wait wait how do we make you
draw more I like how you conveniently
didn't tell us that until I did I know
you didn't tell us that in time so that
we could do it against you but you
couldn't because I clicked uno before I
play you'll see a thing oh sure sure
sure you guys
didn't really pan out for me I really
did not go my way to draw to that
happened there oh no all right I'll do
it again hey you want straight hands way
[ __ ] Ducker just you and me wait oh
yeah what's gonna come down to the wire
is jump in now god damn it yeah that's
suck you can just call you you don't
have to type you can just click up but I
[Laughter]
jack dick him over Wow
I feel like crap randomly pick the color
II doesn't have the chance guys I had a
chance
yeah chance that was really fun that was
ludicrously fun why was that so I told
you we could stop whatever you guys want
to we're starting a new match yeah
another one I'll do another one let's
play okay that's why it's rude hardcore
yeah
[Laughter]
color at the end there because yeah I
appreciate that because
[Laughter]
my hand you on my hand there's a fatal
flaw with that hand would I see no right
well whatever you know what no you know
you know what Jax you know what Bob take
mine I might be working I think we're
just gonna play the long game here cool
Wow yeah mine is actually a pretty
decent hand oh wow yeah
wait prepare to get [ __ ] if this gets
reversed I think we should I think we
should reverse it I think we should not
think that be I think that'd be fun try
that my hand was such a piece [ __ ]
ah well jeez hey look now I can reverse
it oh yeah you do it mark you do it
market no I can't do it not about any
precedent before that how can you and
[ __ ] you Oh for god sakes
shitty titties better challenge it
[Music]
better idea oh yeah better idea
[Applause]
Wow we watch this let's play a regular
one about challenging work so I'm a
daddy
Wow jump in opportunities this is yeah
all right hit the wrong thing
yeah no I'm the card that you want a
mount click that accurately normal
normal everyday standard whoo no don't
stab your friends yeah you know that
type Oh No [ __ ] botanist D got damnit
the [ __ ] button is deep I like red no
one else
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you boy I like blue
I like blue oh my god the Tate is
horrible oh yeah boy that [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
Turnagain okay [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] I thought
I was jumping in I just played a normal
car
[Laughter]
oh I got one of these guys pick a good
color Bob this oh that's alright I'll
accept that here Bob go again and go
again go again oh really
yeah I'm here to help you Bob helped me
when I did take that blob of [ __ ] you in
reality I was betray yeah what you did
exactly I don't know what I did either
play zero and I got your head [ __ ] you
jack oh oh but I have what if though no
I don't yeah I had a reverse that's
different oh god why yeah
[Music]
mark how's that 7n feel at least I know
he's not away he had two three two
threes of the same College rod now wait
has two threes are the same color
nevermind
take this I didn't know that hey I got
one big floppy wieners yeah yeah I
didn't have any cards anyway good this
is going on forever I do that anyhow you
know what for that I'm a thank you like
this
okay okay okay all right okay all right
okay okay no I think way to enjoy the
green [ __ ] not me
[Laughter]
wait
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna end Nikes wait are you gonna
steam my head word I Wow
you know what I don't want to
oh there mark you guys are straight in
the bone zone you know that right you
know that's what my record was actually
called straight out of bone zone god
[ __ ] [ __ ] know how we curse here
in Lehi oh come on man Jesus [ __ ] it I
got AI got a wall give someone else a
chance
Jack can you wait a second all right Bob
get revenge wait your turn you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes this is this is what you just chill
out for a minute
we all have [ __ ] Johnny know how you
play wait aah no how about so you don't
have yellow ha wait you don't know that
other than the fact I told you work this
out yeah you have yellow now don't you
oh wow that works challenge challenge
challenge him he was drawing for that
[ __ ] there's no wait halogen no wait
wait what would happen if you challenge
no no that's not what it was about about
dis and dis No
ah hey teehee [ __ ] you
Oh God bündchen you're not fooling
anyone Wade you're not fooling anyone at
all swearing like crazy right he's won
no challenge you don't know Marc's
mission is just to make the shittiest
hand you have to think come on okay well
fine if someone's drawing cards and then
they play something don't challenge is
real girthy yeah my hands I'm gonna take
Jack if I if I taken weights hand he
wouldn't take it right back was the
problem yeah but you're such a [ __ ] now
look what's happening Oh we'll get him
Oh No oh nice oh my it was complaining I
had I had like yeah here we go
how many cards you have wait is it the
number of car
the type of you can't do anything with
all of the heat that [ __ ] I'll bet you
I've got that color yep like a jump in
I'll make it still that color why would
you make it the color that he wanted I
don't know cuz I don't care I've got a
salt raid like full speed go come on
go Wade go I got your back buddy thanks
buddy
don't don't don't just don't just would
you just make it the color that he needs
no it didn't he didn't know gonna make
it alright I'm gonna challenge the [ __ ]
out of what he was drawing no challenge
no challenge me wait if I play a 1 or a
6 can you change the color yes which one
one got it here we'll skip them entirely
ah joke's on you guys oh [ __ ] oh right
is safe right yeah I don't know about
that
well just in case yeah I'm gonna play on
that too oh nice nice play oh oh no why
did I do
[ __ ] I [ __ ] miss click to jump in and
[Music]
[Laughter]
the wrong color yeah obviously the one
he had I'm going again huh weird crap
it's amazing how the longest [ __ ]
hell come on just let me have it
no no no come on so what color do we
think he has I have no idea no clue [ __ ]
you guys [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] me that Doris yeah friendship works
I think it actually is about as close to
real world friendship as it gets
[ __ ] you well let's trade mark why would
you do that blue I had cuss but why
though to get better car remember how
close we were to Mike to remember it
remember really gobble and some [ __ ]
right now no this is Mark's hand again I
became [ __ ] cuz I touch it there I fixed
it it's not red or blue anymore
make it red that's not Reggie you see
what happens with work touches cards
what do they do
I don't know over there hey blue no
power you must protect your way never
read the wind did we just did you have
to read for no oh keep it yellow I can
screw Bob keep it yellow no what if I
couldn't do anything else why is this
what you give me
you said you keep a yellow 30 seconds
ago [ __ ] come on let's keep it
yellow thirty seconds ago no we won't
rewind right now and see where what he
said exactly I made I played the wrong
one well sure there we go hey come on
now
rude turn on each other
oh oh you asshat why thank [ __ ] god
that ended yeah god that was like 30
minutes but are you guys done with you
know I got aggro unfortunately bro I
would go okay all right I'm staying oh
my god this [ __ ] hand though I gotta
go I already zhis anyway come back no
[Laughter]
scream
[Music]
you